allez personnage maigre es-tu tellement
intéressé par le grand homme
qu'il sort de la ville imparfait et il
m'a demandé si je m'occupe de la loi il
va s'en occuper a montré un bon moment tu
me connais seul tu vois c'est un
test moral que soi-même
je  croyez Marsalis, mon mari, votre
patron vous a dit de me sortir et de faire
ce que je veux,
que vous puissiez ou non maintenir une
nuit sauvage du combat, vous pouvez ressentir une légère
tache, la fierté ne fait que blesser, cela n'arrive jamais
au cinquième, votre cul descend j'ai
dire pour jouer avec des matchs vous vous
brûlez
nous aurions dû nous asseoir les gars pour ce genre d'
affaire nous ne sommes pas un danger
je vais préparer le mode menace savant
oh je suis désolé ai-je brisé votre
concentration descendez descendez vous avez
un cadavre  dans une voiture - devant dans un garage
merci
tu ne détestes pas ça hé quels
silences inconfortables john travolta
samuel l.jackson uma thurman harvey keitel
tim roth amanda plummer maria de
Medeiros bing rings Eric Stoltz rosanna
arquette
Christopher Walken et Bruce Willis
l  regarder quelque chose pour lui étant mon
ami Logan ton pote
un nouveau film de Quentin Tarantino le
réalisateur de Reservoir Dogs
toi